it's not often that I tell people to
simply not buy a new device that I'm
reviewing companies typically improve
their tack year-to-year or make
something new that tries to stand out in
the market but not this time the Galaxy
Tab s6 is samsung latest tablet but when
I started to use it and test it I kept
finding things about it that are worse
than last year's model I'll go over
every corner that was cut in just a bit
but first I just want to say that there
are two alternative tablets listed down
in the description that are much better
buys both Android and iPad OS the tab s6
lights biggest selling point is the
price coming in at just $350 so $50 less
than last year's s5e with that $50 price
drop it has gained two features that the
s5 II didn't have and that is s-pen
support and a headphone jack the biggest
competitors to the s5 II
Apple's budget iPad has both of those I
can see why samsung added them
unfortunately in order to have those
features and also meet a competitive
price point and ended up killing this
device for me personally and the one
group of people that this would have
actually been perfect for should just go
and buy last year's s5e let's start with
the display I love the s5 ease sharp
olla display which was fantastic for
watching video with its deep blacks and
for reading with it's over 4 million
pixels but now it is a dull TFT display
which is 2.4 million pixels and the
difference is definitely noticeable
because of that change
it is almost 30% thicker and 15% heavier
now it's still usable as a tablet it's
just not as good on the sides we have
dual speakers which are actually fairly
loud and sound good but still not as
good as the s5 ease quad speakers
probably the most frustrating change is
the removal of the keyboard dock
connector I love that we can attach
keyboards to these newer tablets and use
many of them for serious typing and the
s5 es worked fairly well for that so it
makes no sense to me why Samsung got rid
of it my only guess is that they didn't
want to invest the money to make a new
keyboard so now you will have to just
use a third party Bluetooth keyboard
that won't be as good now let's talk
about the pen support that they gave us
when they took away the keyboard
benefit is that the S Pen is now
included in the box but it's super
lightweight and kind of cheap feeling
when we draw on the screen there is a
massive delay probably the worst that
I've experienced it seems to be a mix of
screen delay and the graphics not
keeping up because they did leave Aries
almost like frames are being sometimes
dropped and this is just what simple
drawing not something that's complex
like a project with multiple layers
overall the pen experience is quite poor
it's worse than the budget surface go to
and much worse than a basic iPad that
cost 329 but most of the time comes in
well under that we'll have some links in
the description because of it lag in the
fact that iOS has so many great apps
with pen supports if you're thinking
about buying in the s6 light just for
the pen I always strongly suggest going
and picking up one of these basic iPads
instead let me quickly cover cameras
last year we had 13 megapixels on the
rear and eight on the front but a year
later they got worse we had eight
megapixels on the back and five on the
front now on top of that we no longer
have the ultra-fast fingerprint scanner
on the side and now we're going back to
the days of just punching in your PIN or
using basic facial recognition which is
kind of unreliable and can be fooled
with pictures now for the one true
complaint that I had with the s5e last
year the processor we had the budget
snapdragon 670 which was quite slow and
made the tablet sluggish so when I saw
that Samsung got rid of it this year I
was happy well until I tested it this
year samsung is using their own 8-quart
Exynos 96 11 but when I tested it I
found that it is actually slower than
already slow 670 and keep in mind it's
been a year so the biggest issue wasn't
improved now graphics did get slightly
faster but not enough to make a
difference in the real world and the
worst part of all is that this chip is
less efficient so the battery life
rating has gone down by three hours
battery itself is the same but that
included charger is now a 7.5 watt slow
charger instead of that 18 watt fast
charger so we'll take more than twice as
long to charge and the battery lasts
about 25%
yes I am being very critical of this
tablet where many other reviewers are
being much nicer almost too nice and not
even mentioning what has gone down in
quality and yes you can still use this
buy it use it as a regular tablet and
they will do okay you'll have a decent
experience with simple apps and maybe
basic games web browsing maybe watching
some movies but that doesn't mean that
you should buy it
Samson went from an overall fantastic
tablet that had a few shortcomings to
one that is overall the complete
opposite as a few good things going for
it but if you don't need the pen support
and don't mind using a USB type-c
adapter or a Bluetooth earbuds just go
buy the s5 II instead or you can spend a
little bit more money and check out
their really good standard tab s6 I'll
go ahead and leave some links in the
description and you guys can watch the
tab s6 review right over there thank you
guys for watching let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below click above to subscribe this man
max max tech and I will see you in the
next video
[Music]